hey youtubers is Charlie new Black
Panther footage to break down and
surprise surprise they did not mention
Winter Soldier at all he is still on ice
in Wakanda you may have heard about
Marvel dropping all this footage for
journalists a couple days ago so they
showed off a couple really cool
unfinished Black Panther scenes there
was even a mistake that Lupita Nyong'o
actually got into when she was
performing a stunt during one of the big
action scenes that might make it into
the movie because she stumbled and
recovered and it looks so good on camera
so if you're new to the channel there's
a new round of the Spider Man giveaway
going on it's for the action figures all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so the big black panther scenes i'll
start with the action stuff but they
showed off some of the heart some of the
fun stuff the culture of Wakanda as well
as the more regal aspects of black
panther because very shortly during the
movie he's going to become the newly
anointed king although he effectively
became king after his father died back
during civil war but they actually have
to have that ceremony so that's going to
be a big part of the movie the first big
action scene was the dorm ology
instituting a strike against a bunch of
other commandos in the middle of the
night so it was mostly focused on Lupita
nyong'o's character she's playing Nakia
she's a character from the comics in a
Koi a is being played by tonigh gurira
they're like the two main door Milosh a
characters but there's going to be a
whole bunch others but obviously not
every character is going to get a big
story during the movie they're just two
of the fiercest warriors you'll
experience the culture of the door
malate sort of the warrior wives of the
king of Wakanda during the movie so you
get their perspective on things so will
be this faceless group of warriors like
iron man's iron Legion just a bunch of
robots that are CG on screen they'll
actually have a living breathing culture
that you'll experience there was another
scene with the two of them dancing in a
big ceremony denies character looks at
new Peeta Nyong'o and says you look
really good right now and she's like I
know so they're not completely egoless
they love to have fun they're not like
stormtroopers in the Star Wars movies
you'll actually get to see what they do
when they're not busy ripping people's
faces off with their claws the next big
scene they showed off was Black Panthers
coronation there was this big procession
of them going to warrior Falls where
Black Panthers dressed in these really
special gold robes he vows before this
woman in white and be
the coronation ceremony so make all the
Disney Lion King jokes you want circle
of life you will see him be crowned king
of Wakanda it'll be this big great
ceremony then they showed off a look at
ulysses klaw and some of the villains in
a big casino scenes it turns into a big
action set piece so Black Panther and
the Dorma logic are spying on Ulysses
Klaw as he meets with Everett Ross if
you haven't read the comics he serves a
couple important functions that you
didn't really see during Civil War he's
kind of like the pencil pusher in the
comics and he's the son of general
Everett Ross so as you can imagine the
Apple does not fall from the tree his
father's a dick he's kind of a dick so
as he's meeting with ulysses klaw and
his group he walks up and says you
brought quite an entourage
you got a mixtape coming out and ulysses
klaw gets all pissed off and it devolves
into a firefight it becomes this big
action set piece inside the casino so
there's any mistake ulysses klaw sort of
like the big MCU Red Skull type villain
the only footage that they didn't really
show off and nobody was talking about
was a Michael B Jordan as kill mugger
he wears a costume with this special
mask it looks exactly like it does in
the comics so they're being very true to
his origin you can't really call him the
Winter Soldier or the Loki of the movie
but he does have a tragic history just
like those other characters but unless
they make some big changes from the
comics he's not going to be super close
with Black Panther it could be one of
those things that they do change because
they're supposed to be some flashbacks
to when Black Panther went to college he
went to college in the United States so
when he was growing up he spent a lot of
time in America but kill monger did the
exact same thing and they're both highly
learned very smart people you have to
imagine that Black Panther is just as
smart as Tony Stark
he actually uses his money to fund the
Ultimates which is the biggest most
complex cosmic group that they have in
the Marvel Comics right now they work
with people like Galactus they fight
cosmic entities so all the power levels
of those people are way off the charts
is crazy but it just reminds you it
would have scientists that Black Panther
is in addition to being a warrior it's
just that his character is so grounded
he's a lot easier to latch on to than a
character like Tony Stark I know
everybody's been talking about the tone
of the Marvel films if you're looking
for a serious Marvel film that is black
panther there are very few characters in
the Marvel Universe that are
more serious than him because he has to
be a king so he has the weight of his
country on his shoulders and this is the
map of Wakanda you can see that it's
very big it's made up of several cities
the Golden City is just the capital that
you see most of the time but there's all
kinds of tribes all over the place so he
has to deal with that on a practical
level day to day but he also has to deal
with all the big Avengers problems that
are happening Thanos the Infinity
Gauntlet civil war all this other
craziness that we're going to get into
so the movie is just going to convey a
lot of that along with the fun like they
do like to have fun which a lot as I
said you'll experience through the
Dermalogica characters like you know
very hardcore group with a very strong
tradition but they also really know how
to have a good time so one of the big
things that the Black Panther movie has
to do is convey the culture of Wakanda
in how it's so different from the other
Avengers movies that you've seen because
with the exception of people like Thor
in the guardians of the galaxy most of
the characters that we've been
interacting with are American characters
so they're just as big side of the
Marvel Universe that Black Panther has a
chance to convey so I don't think there
was ever any concern about it but Kevin
Feige reiterated that Black Panther is
going to be one of the most important
new characters they're introducing in
phase 3 to the rest of the Marvel movies
so even if it takes a while for Black
Panther 2 to come out the sequel he's
going to be very important to the other
Marvel movies in phase 4 like they've
even said the Doctor Strange 2 might not
come out during phase 4 they might even
not do phases anymore they're not even
going to say what the movies are going
to be after phase 3 is over they're
going to hold that for like a couple
years he said as long as possible we're
not going to reveal what our plans are
so he's already said a couple of things
that just make it sound like he's going
to be doing smaller crossover movies the
way he's done with Iron Man and
spider-man they're not going to rely on
tentpole films quite as much they're
only going to make those big Avengers
films but it's not going to follow the
strict phase one phase two phase
restructure that they done before but
all that speculation we can talk about
that after comic-con and that's when
they'll be showing off real black
panther footage they literally just got
done shooting the movie as I'm posting
this video Chadwick Boseman was just
holding up some cookies there was a shot
of the cake so they are all done
shooting Black Panthers they've started
cutting it they're also still editing
thor ragnarok so don't expect too much
from the 2018 movies like infinity war
or black panther till like way later
this year most of the time is going to
be spent hyping up spider-man homecoming
after guardians comes out and then thor
ragnarok so a lot of you were asking me
about the x-men movies speaking of 2018
they confirm three movies are being
released from the x-men universe in 2018
you already knew about Deadpool too but
they changed a bunch of days so there is
a new infinity war to talk about but I'm
going to save that for another video
I'll explain like the x-men movies that
are coming out next year for Deadpool 2
that's now coming out June 1st 2018
it was previously going to be released
in February and it was going to compete
with the Black Panther movie so now
there really is no competition for Black
Panther so it is going to do gangbusters
but they are releasing the New Mutants
movie April 13th if you don't know
anything about the New Mutants movie
I've done a couple videos about it
that's really their big risk because
it's an untested property like will
people like these characters in the
third x-men film this is kind of funny
the way people are reacting to this is
the Dark Phoenix saga they're actually
calling it Dark Phoenix now in that
supposed to come out November 2nd
they're supposed to start shooting it
later this year
so be Turner James McAvoy Professor X
were just like yeah we're going to get
ready to do that and they billed it as
sort of a soft reboot of the x-men
universe but if you guys want I will
totally do a separate video for all that
x-men movie news Deadpool 2 is really
like the solid bet if Thanos version of
cable should be very interesting they've
already done some costume testing so
they're in pre-production for that right
now they'll be shooting really soon so
all kinds of crazy comic-book stuff
happening and yes there is some behind
the scenes stuff for Scarlet Witch
envision you guys have been asking me
about so I'll probably do a video sort
of explain their powers in the history
of their relationship believe all your
requests for Marvel videos in the
comments below
congratulations to area Tarka you win
last week's spider-man giveaway please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you
for that next video you can click here
for brand-new thor ragnarok
and you can click here for my other
Black Panther videos thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys in the next video